the fellows caelers this is when mister
pepper sweet cadorna fair to day i'm
really excited to sew
then awake antoine
minimizing the amount of good contact
with the grand master de scion tc price the
robots and surge at this can be done with
the zero percent contact
mini 13 never ever tasje grand de feed
the scientists wonder how it is even
possible and pulled up  the video of the
test this test shot europe flipping
over and working using it samples talk
about thinking outside the box
wow
the thief and robot arm experiment us
no between pricing conclusion
at first the robot arm it reviews
groupers' to give you could successfully i
learned to  perform a lover in a liter
experiment the gripper
was lame measurement the robot unable to
fetch fingers
scientific spectacular video we
try the robot  ing to boosterbox around and
osv link to pick up
youtube found this
you see it right instead of using the
fingers de robot vice de perfect angle
to smash die and open the guest box de force
de gripper and tap the box
that's sam serious dedication to solving
the task at hand
gravel in the next experiment group of
robots becomes test the fine food and the
get angry and the soviets in one and warm
and and word crypt we de light and no
further instructions
first they learn to  use the lights to
communicate the presence of food and
pleasant to each other and poor project
this demonstrates that when trying to
maximize the probability of the survival
of van en tire colonie
de concept of communication and
corporation kenny mercy van frans Simpel
your own networks absolutely beautiful
and what is equally beautiful ringcredible is the
glitter of the nori word system was
created at foster's soft reservation
the robots learned to deceive each other
by lighting that the foot  single
down the poison to take a 13 pages and
increase their chances and these die
seriously after all for mary word system and
the few simple
euro networks mind-blowing the thief and
tha was s to fix fawlty sorting
computer program
soul eater chieftain perfect score from
changing  and i think big is that
peschar targeting the program myself it
oil provider emté output and of course
you know is de arnhemmers that is with
ink a kind of problem soft
make sure to have a look at the paper
gut anymore experiment that was
symbolism in  kloetinge case for the
iphone the bin in a physical simulation
program to get and edge with a year of
research in proving that such perez face
it is clearly capable of links that kind of
easter sar value steam edgy nation with
whom has a make sure to formulate a
problem sweet pepper locker i is that
one you will try to use look poles
capable of common sense to soften
when a car chase dan tess the korean
lol aan necessario ways to go fa  star
or you do now part of the prom play
effects of the core i5 in join this
episode
please make sure to have look at a page
homepage in the video discription where you
know i got really cool by spot early
access to the videos or getting your
takes shown in the video description and
more
so much and for your generous support
and i'll see you next time